si yo les diera la fracción un tercio
podría reescribir las y multiplicó el
numerador y el denominador por 2 2 por 1
es 22 por 13 6 y así sabemos que un
tercio es igual a dos sextos esto es
verdadero un tercio es otra manera de
referirnos a dos sextos y ya que sabemos
esto cuáles estas ecuaciones con
imágenes serán verdaderas bueno vamos a
comenzar con esta de acá
aquí tenemos tres secciones iguales cada
una de estas secciones va a ser un
tercio y tenemos uno de esos tercios
iluminado si vemos el lado derecho
tenemos el mismo rectángulo dividido en
seis partes iguales así que está
dividido en sextos y tenemos dos de
estos iluminados aquí lo importante a
darse cuenta es que aquí dividimos el
mismo rectángulo en tres partes iguales
y aquí lo dividimos el mismo rectángulo
en seis partes iguales estamos
comparando fracciones del mismo entero
y podemos ver que si tomamos estos dos
cuadritos magenta y los ponemos acá van
a cubrir la misma área que este
rectángulo más grande así que esta es
una buena explicación visual de por qué
un tercio es igual a dos sextos ya que
estamos tomando el mismo rectángulo la
misma unidad la dividimos en tres partes
y tomamos una parte de estas y ahora
tomamos el mismo rectángulo y lo
dividimos en 36 y tomamos dos partes y
con esto tenemos iluminada la misma área
así que un tercio de acá es lo mismo que
dos sextos de acá entonces lo importante
es darnos cuenta que estamos tomando una
tercera parte y dos sextas partes de un
rectángulo igual del mismo tamaño
ahora si vemos estas figuras de aquí
abajo vemos que efectivamente aquí
tenemos un tercio de esta figura ya que
la tenemos dividida en tres partes
iguales y estamos iluminando una de
ellas y esto de aquí son dos sextos de
esta figura
tenemos seis partes iguales y estamos
iluminando dos de ellas y bueno por una
parte sabemos que un tercio es igual a
dos sextos pero estas no son imágenes
iguales esta área iluminada de aquí es
más pequeña que el área iluminada acá
así que se pueden preguntar bueno porque
esto no se cumple porque no funciona
porque esté un tercio no es igual a este
dos sextos pues porque estamos tomando
dos sextos de un hexágono más grande y
aquí tenemos una tercera parte de una
figura más pequeña comparada con la
figura de la que estamos tomando dos
sextos es más grande así que no podemos
comparar fracciones de diferentes
enteros dos sextos de un entero más
grande van a ser más grandes que una
tercera parte de un entero más pequeño
el único momento en el que un tercio es
igual a dos sextos es cuando pertenecen
a un mismo entero como lo que vimos aquí
arriba así que esto no se cumple y por
la misma razón esto de aquí abajo
tampoco se va a cumplir
y esto de aquí es un tercio esto de acá
son dos sextos pero nuevamente es un
tercio de un círculo más pequeño y estos
son dos sextos de un círculo más grande
así que esto no se cumple y aplicamos la
misma lógica a estas dos imágenes de acá
aquí ya no vamos a estar hablando de un
tercio y dos sextos a ver déjame ver
tenemos esta imagen dividida en uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho así
que estamos hablando de octavos y aquí
tenemos iluminados uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis seis de esos octavos y aquí
lo comparamos con este entero que está
dividido en cuartos y tenemos iluminados
tres cuartos y aunque es cierto que seis
octavos es igual a tres cuartos seis
dividido entre dos es 38 dividido entre
dos es cuatro y recuerden que si
multiplicamos o dividimos tanto el
numerador como el denominador por la
misma cantidad vamos a tener una
fracción equivalente y aunque seis
octavos es equivalente a tres cuartos
esta imagen no es verdadera
seis octavos sería igual o equivalente a
tres cuartos si y sólo si tuviéramos
diamantes del mismo tamaño estos dos no
son del mismo tamaño así que este
enunciado no es verdadero lo mismo para
este de aquí abajo los círculos de
entrada son de tamaños diferentes así
que tomando fracciones de diferentes
enteros definitivamente no vamos a poder
compararlas
en este último estamos tomando
fracciones del mismo entero tienen la
misma forma como de flecha extraña que
está apuntando hacia la izquierda pero
es la misma forma en ambos lados y vemos
que aquí dividimos esta figura en
octavos en ocho partes iguales de las
cuales hemos seleccionado vamos a verlo
en amarillo para que lo puedan notar 1 2
3 4 5 6 y aquí lo hemos dividido en
cuatro partes en cuartos de los cuales
están iluminados tres así que tenemos
tres cuartos
este enunciado es verdadero ya sabemos
que seis octavos es equivalente a tres
cuartos pero esta imagen de aquí
visualmente nos está mostrando esto ya
que estamos tomando seis octavos del
mismo entero y lo comparamos con tres
cuartos de ese mismo entero y esto lo
pueden ver aquí esta área que yo que voy
a iluminar en otro color para que se
note esta área que estoy resaltando
estos seis triángulos de la misma área
de acá son equivalentes a estos tres
paralelo gramos de acá éstos tienen la
misma área
podemos tomar uno de estos como este que
estoy resaltando más crece equivalente a
este otro de aquí
vamos a hacerlo para todos
este otro que estoy resaltando con otro
color es equivalente a no sé vamos a
elegir este de acá y finalmente yo creo
que ustedes ya se dieron cuenta de qué
es lo que va a pasar este otro de aquí
es equivalente a este de acá por lo que
tenemos la misma fracción sombreada
simplemente tenemos este dividido en más
partes iguales al menos comparada con la
de acá pero son fracciones equivalentes
y esta imagen nos muestra que seis
octavos es equivalente a tres cuartos ya
que estamos trabajando con el mismo
entero